builets and washing facilities are
available in the foyer
area members of the public whilst you
are entitled to film or take photographs
during this meeting can I please
emphasize that you this should be done
without disruption to the meeting and
can only be done from a designated area
in the public seating can I please
therefore ask you to raise your hand
clearly in the air if you wish to take
photographs or film this evening
members there is a need to use
microphones durin this meeting when I
invite you to speak please speak clearly
into the microphone in front of you
microphones are needed for the hearing
Loop and for the live stream members
voting will be done on a show of hands
in line with the Constitution I will ask
for a show of hands for then against
recommendations and will also ask for a
show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from
voting
agenda item number one apology apologies
for absence members we have received
apologies of for absence from councelor
Mrs Danielle belon councelor Mrs
Christine Mason councelor Elliot Mason
councelor Bob mil and councelor Gary
Meyers uh members are there any other
apologies for absence nobody's
indicating thank you um agenda item
number two substitute members uh members
Council
Richard Lindon will substitute for
councelor Bob mil and councelor Ian
Foster for councelor Mrs
belon agenda item three non non-members
attending uh councelor Stanley thank
you and agenda item four minutes of the
meeting held on the 3D of October
2023 members are the minutes
agreed thank you members agenda item
item number five to receive Declarations
of Interest members are there any
Declarations of
Interest nobody's indicating thank you
agenda item six Highway Rangers members
I will to invite Marcus hotton the
council's director of environment to
introduce this
report good evening members thank you
for the opportunity to to present this
um I think this is a follow-up report
from the previous one that came back
here a couple of months ago the request
the and scrutinies come come back and so
really basically it's just looking at
whether there's any ways in which the uh
Highway ranges could be funded so it's
it's trying to identify
70,000 um principally from either the
sep funding or from in some way from the
Open Spaces uh existing budget um I
think in conclusion I think you know it
was almost scraping the Bott bottom of
the barrel thinking all truthfulness and
trying to through the Open Spaces
budgets we found some um through the
sort of um Pavilions um perhaps there's
some budget there when sort of um
conversing with the assets team and and
again some other budget outside of the
Open Spaces which was to car park
maintenance that was used for grounds
maintenance issues so in terms of the
recommendation that I put forward there
just be aware that um in many ways it's
uh the 770,000 although it'd be funding
with the high ranges it would still have
to give uh quite a bit of priority to
ensuring that the car park Grounds
Maintenance was at least given Priority
First so in I in conclusion there is
very little budget available so and so
it's um hence the sort of um the sort of
um points I've made I'm happy to take
any questions thank
you thank you Marcus members are
questions uh councilor
[Music]
wam Madame chairman thank you very much
indeed uh it's a mixture of questions
and statements um Madam chairman the
clue of this service is in the title
when it's entitled Highway Rangers um
and by definition it is Essex County
Council that have responsibility for our
highways um so uh the same dilemma is
facing this Administration has faced my
own Administration just over a year ago
in the sense this is a service that uh
has been passed out to Rockford District
Council uh and uh I think it's important
that we make the point that
uh whilst undoubtedly all members across
all parties want to do the best for
their residents there is a line by which
you have to turn around and say is it
fundamentally right that we take on the
function of another Authority so I think
that is a fundamental Point uh to deal
with here my sympathy sympathies are
with the current administration because
they have the same dilemma that we had
just over a year ago as to how this is
funded because because it is an
important Service uh no one is denying
that but uh in terms of funding what we
put in was a fix and I fully admit that
it was a fix to deal with it in the
short term so that actually individuals
carried on being employed because that
was important and the service continued
to be provided but it was never seen as
a long-term fix it was seen as a fix
while we considered negotiating with
ess6 County Council and being in the
strongest possible terms uh to continue
with the service now in terms of the
report uh paragraph 3 3.1 I think sums
it all up for us here in Rochford in as
much as um the implication is there that
if we continue to fund it in whatever
way we continue to fund it it is
actually a cut in another service uh and
you will never get me actually uh
agreeing to fund a service that another
Authority should provide by cutting
stuff that we should be doing for our
own residents so I have real difficulty
uh in supporting any of the
recommendations not because if in any
way I want to be destructive but it is a
simple fact that by agreeing to any of
the options and I I really applaud the
fact that work has been done to try and
find options um the fundamental thing is
that it will be a reduction in service
somewhere it's playing around with
figures and if we're talking of the
order of £70,000 or whatever it is that
is £70,000 less to spend on something
else so fundamentally Madame chairman uh
I have an issue with this but not with
rodford District Council but my question
because I did say it would be mixed with
the statement and question is have we
got any update on 1. two in relation to
uh to the various points that were made
in a previous meeting uh and and uh for
the reasons I've set out personally I
can't support any uh I can't support
recommendation one thank you very much
indeed uh thank you Council Orton before
uh Marcus comes in and answers the
question that you've raised about the
recommendations from the previous
meeting perhaps Marcus could also
explain how the fundings have been found
for this um as you say possibly another
fix but they have been found um so
therefore they won't be coming my belief
from other services but Marcus will fill
us in on
that thank you sir so the um the savings
that can be found are from umly The
Pavilion budget fund and so many ways I
think assets have just taken a review of
what's been all allocated so it's
historical so it's around um Pavilions
that that are currently in the process
of being leased or have been leased but
budget maintenance budget is still
allocated to those so I think they feel
that that there is money that could be
offered um up to services without
impacting other services Council W is
correct and that that could still be
used for something else I think that
that's the point I was making in the
report there that um this has probably
got to be considered in The Wider budget
setting the medium-term financial
strategy you know that saving could be
something else again so I take your
points I think the
£3,000 uh that we spoke about for sort
of Grounds Maintenance of um car Parks
will be a straight transfer so in many
ways we felt that we probably could do
you know
um if I'm being brutally honest I'm
slightly embarrassed I didn't even
realize they were paying someone to do
those works I think that's something we
should have as Grounds Maintenance team
picks up previously I think we can get
better value for money so I think that
that that isn't so much of an impact but
the £40,000 on on the um on the sort of
um Pavilions absolutely could be used
for something else in in Long saving is
a saving I'm always bit nervous to do do
that in front of A1 officer because you
you find a saving for one thing they go
thank you very much we'll we'll use that
for something else and but you know but
I can only present what I can present in
this report I think Other M you're
talking about the recommendations is it
under 1.2 so just the clarity was that
um you're asking for progress on those
it's not part of the report I'm happy to
yes please Madam chairman so was that um
I'm looking here and I think that's the
is this is this R3 sorry I looked R1 two
three and four I presume well I think
one self exlan so number two is is we're
coming back here um on on recommendation
free to draft OS can be circulated to
Paris and Town Council that has gone out
um we're having some expressions of
interest that the devil's in the detail
of that you know so I I think there
could be some work that could come out
of that but I I believe um just my
experience of working with parish and
town councils previously um it's not a
quick U um sort of U solution usually
can only takes quite a few months if if
not a year to resolve uh and that's just
the nature of Parish Council so I think
there's something in the future but I
wonder if by April we will have
something resoled with the pares I I'd
be um pessimistic and the last one the
letter has been written but I think you
know just on the on the last points um
again just you know from an Ethics
perspective you remember that that all
they've done this to all authorities um
so I would be um surprised if I was
being honest if ethics would reverse on
their decision just because it wouldn't
be just for one Authority they'd have to
do it for all so he's just the precent
so you know i' you know any optimism
there I would um be very cautious that
thank you um did you want to come back
on that Council if I may just very
briefly Madam chairman um look it's not
part of the recommendations tonight but
uh um just to endorse my earlier points
I would be firmly against recommendation
three because I think it's absolutely
outrageous that uh um we and I don't
think it's outrageous of us but I think
it's outrageous that we should just find
another way of funding it good for
creative ity but I don't really see why
the parish or the Town Council um should
be lumbered with the cost of something
which fundamentally is ethics
responsibility but uh um I just want to
make that point thank
you I will come back there because I do
have a little bit of background
information on this the letter that went
out to the parish councils I believe
they were asked to respond by the 30th
of November so there is a timeline
around that I know you use the word
Lumber councelor w
um I would
choose perhaps a different word because
our
residents they pay taxes they just want
something
delivered here we have something that
can really affect them especially Road
Safety so we do have to consider
sometimes that perhaps you might want to
say it's taking up the slack from ESS
County coun and I agree with you 100%
that it's their responsibility but we do
have to act for our
residence and on that point if I may
very happy to withdraw the word lumbered
um it's a bit of an untiy word but uh
the concept but also I'm against double
taxation uh and it is for that reason
that I was saying lumed uh not within
the context of the service itself which
like you I agree is a very valuable
service and it's right that we look at
all creative means to provide it just
for clarification thank you thank you
and I I think um the word would be
essics have put us into a very very
difficult situation uh Council cross um
thank you chairman um just on the
subject of uh double taxation I'm I
agree with councilor won um but we're
used to double taxation aren't we we're
we're taxed at source with our income we
pay you know VAT on on things and and
many other forms of taxes so we're
already triple quadruple taxed in in
many ways um I'd just like to ask um
Marcus a couple of questions um whether
there's any commitment uh to um the
pilion leases whether we can just cut um
cut that funding without any
implications I know there's nothing sort
of in the risk section but um and also
the car park maintenance we presumably
have a contract with somebody at the
moment is that a is that a rolling thing
or can that be terminated without any
any implications thank
you
um so the Pavilion um my understanding
from the asset team there isn't any risk
I wouldn't say it's an oversight but
it's the tidying up of um just just
budgets have historically been allocated
to what were the football Pavilions but
are now leased out and so um you know as
part of those terms they pay for the
electricity that sort of thing you know
and there's still budgets allocated for
that that can be tucked in and and
claimed back without impacting upon the
council um the second question it's it's
it's almost uh an ad hoc Arrangements I
think they almost call upon a sort of a
grounds maintenance contract as and when
they wish to use them so there's there's
no long-term
commitment does that answer your
question councel yes thank you lovely
thank you uh councelor Mrs Gadson um
this is more of a statement um R three
the proposal to be circulated to parish
and town councils um over the last six
throughout the summer um the local
Parish Council that I serve on has been
inundated with um requests for verges
Alleyways to could be cut back and the
parish council has been subsidizing this
along but like all levels of council
we're all struggling with budgets and I
know for a fact that although we haven't
replied so I won't name the council but
we have come to a decision that we can
no longer subsidize
a service that we are not responsible
for our Rangers are doing their job but
we cannot be the cane cannot be kicked
down the road it feels like it's been
kicked down to you to us here and I
really feel that you know the pressures
on the parish councils are no more
different to us so I I don't know how
you're going to resolve this to be
honest without service residents are
already upset this summer about the
deterioration in Services they've been
receiving so this should be really
interesting Marcus did you want like to
come back on that statement at
all just know thank thank you noted but
I do know your concerns thank
you councelor
Foster thank you madam chairman um
apologies if I missed something um on
Page 6 .
five item three at the top of the page a
transfer of the grounds maintenance who
who does the grounds maintenance at the
moment first
point I think we're referring to the um
Grounds Maintenance of of the car Parks
yeah who does it currently so I I'm I
don't have the information to hand it's
assets that oversee that but I think
it's just um on ad hoc sort of basis so
it's whoever they wish to appoint at the
time what I'm what I'm trying to get at
I see it very simply there's some
current work being done by somebody in
the council which we transfer to the
Rangers um how did that save 30,000 to
pay the
Rangers sorry it's a a 30,000 budget
that's used to pay contractors so rather
than pay contractors they could pay they
could use that sorry sorry I Haden made
it clear thank you
okay did you have another question uh
councilor Foster no that's cover thank
you thank you councilor
sparing thank you chairman um with
regard to the relationship with County
um with the best will in the world our
leader can write to Essex County Council
but I'm aware or certainly as last year
that a number of councils Harish um
District councils have already just
accepted that the bill is going to be on
their doorstep now essics are not
budging one iota and I'm Mr H may be a
to confirm this but I I believe that
over 50% of the district across the
county have already accepted that they
will pay in future I believe that was a
figure we were given I think Mr Hutton's
report accurately reflects the various
options that the Administration has got
in front of them it's going to have to
be up to them to decide how they want to
operate this very important service
thank you
chairman thank you um Marcus did you
want to come back here to on that no
you're fine um just quickly uh councelor
lambor yes can can I ask um Mr Hopton
whether the figures that he's quoting
here of 30,000 and 40,000 whether
they've been um validated by the finance
department I yes they have soet the
asset team was sitting down with Finance
when when I know open space man went
through them with them so that that's so
almost forur just that it was discovered
rather than planned if I'm being
brutally honest but yes they have they
are aware of the
savings any more questions no thank you
councelor Mrs gson sorry
Marcus is it a statutory requirement the
the esss County Council provides this
service and if it's a statutory
requirement I should wait for you to say
yes or no
really yes so if it's a statutory
requirement how do they legally get away
without providing that
service now if I was a lawyer and could
give you an answer I probably be working
here would I i' be it's um that's a good
question uh I think this it says there
isn't there's a duty but how you
interpretate that duty is uh up to
essics so they may have a duty to
maintain the highway but what's viewed
as maintained of course is is perhaps
where there's there's scope for for
definition so I'm not a legal expert if
I was then you know I'd probably be
somewhere else today would one not say
that when a service is provided to a
certain standard that that becomes the
norm therefore that would
[Music]
become
um I I do take your point but it's fesic
to make that decision um and you know
and so some of they will say is
um almost of amenity value rather than
essential so for for an example if you
had two foot paths walk running down a a
road and one was overgrown but one
wasn't they would say well that's
perfectly acceptable you can just cross
the road and use the other path it's not
the words I would use but you know so
there's there's safe and then there's
convenient as well and so what they'll
say that's still safe to use um it may
not be convenient but it's safe and and
so that's my understanding this is the
position they take so am I given to
understand that they will do Ranger work
on the highways that are considered
health and safety issues or are they
doing none at
all so um the advice given that they
they do undertake inspections they then
prioritize and then address through
those priorities
um I believe they have quite a lot of
high priority work so again it can still
take a long time to um to do I mean
certainly they they've done um the
occasional piece of work uh in the
districts here um if I'm honest we had
to send our team in afterwards to do it
properly if I'm being really quite cruel
about it um so I wasn't too impressed
but they will said but I think if it's
essential ental they will at least try
to do something but but again same as
the potholes or anything else it takes
time for so basically if we don't
provide disservice our residents are
going to be greatly
affected I think potentially I think
that was that was always a discussion
here that was concern and I think that's
why a lot of the authorities have just
carried on saying do you know what we're
going to do it because there's also gray
areas I mean so there'll be Alleyways
that you could spend as much time
arguing about who's responsible for as
it would be just to clear them the
residents of suffers in the interim
that's make concern thank
you thank you and I think for anybody
who listens to this Rec in their
residents um who report certain issues
they see how long highways take um so
hopefully as our officer explained um
Rochford has already been making so many
areas safe uh Council
award yeah thank you chairman um I don't
want to assume anything but um I take it
they will be restricted to the 30 m hour
areas is that correct and anything over
that is needing to be dealt with by
Essex
highways that that's a good question I
think and that could be where um
possibly any new Arrangement have a
slight weakness in that um all traffic
management that there is an additional
budget there for traffic management so
really would be limited to 30 some 40
mph per hour stuff as well but it's
strictly 30 and you know certainly the
60 m per hour areas you you need traffic
management straight off so again um our
staff are trying to to to do some
traffic management works
um while we're on the subject if if
we're not going to use a south6 parking
partnership there was money allowed to
to buy traffic lights so we could at
least um if it was to continue we could
probably actually undertake some of the
traffic management ourselves as
well good value for money so we may be
able to do some 60 m per hours it really
depends on the individual Road and the
risk assessment that's required at that
time but all 30 m stuff can be done
higher speed limits we need traffic
management thanks yeah of course you can
counselor Ward okay just coming back to
some of the points that other members
have made about double
taxation um and also on R4 on the report
for the leader and I understand what
councilor spurring has said that um
essics by and large are not prepared to
move is there an opportunity and this
has been brought up by other members of
a legal challenge basically because it
is double taxation that's number one and
the fact of of the you know simply as a
statutory Duty possibly could that be
tested legally and has that been looked
into in any way shape or
form certainly I I haven't done so um I
think um if there was an opportunity to
do so then perhaps that been when it
first withdrawn so if you remember it's
now been withdrawn for almost a year the
announcement was about a year ago um uh
from recollection at the time although
this was raised um with Chief Executives
and leaders at the time there didn't
seem to be much of an appetite to to
push back I think you know the I think
the only chance I ever had is is perhaps
is a as a collective um all all councils
have said you know we would we will
challenge this I think there would been
a case but I think you know for Rocher
to have gone on its own I think and if
you don't have the other council's
backing you then you're in a very weak
position so I think that boat sailed
unfortunately
are there any further
questions okay um I have a few sorry
Marcus and a couple of statements
um firstly on the recommendations
recommendation four that the leader of
the council rights to the cabinet member
for essic highways seeking clarification
regarding the provision of the service
um with it the withdrawal of funding for
Highway ranges I think we've moved on
slightly and it will be a meeting with
um the cabinet member leader yourself as
officer and myself um so members um I
quite um relish sitting opposite the
cabinet member of highways to explain to
them how they should be doing their job
um with regard to the towns and Parish
councils um I understand councelor Mrs
Gaston your council's view um but it
might not be the view of all parish and
town councils and I do think that we
need to have that prioritized because
that can share light we none of the
parish councils know how much or
anything like that so there needs to be
a discussion because if you're asked for
a contribution of a couple of thousand
pounds that's different to a large sum
in their budget
um my question um one statement under
circumstances would I support any
um reduction in the cuts of our Open
Spaces um in seeking any funding um I
don't know about any other members here
but for my award it was something that I
was constantly chased on grass cutting
so I I can't um support that being um
cut that sounds good doesn't it at all
um to find funding for this um what I
would like to ask is have you got a
breakdown of what areas because you know
them far better than essit County
Council as well um which are prioritized
for reasons of
safety it's probably something we could
produce um you know I think just from um
speaking to the not so there is areas
that we um would do if highways hadn't
send some work through so often we would
Direct by highways did undertake work
but if they if it was a quiet month
there were things that we proactively do
so we'd say you know we'd go and do MERS
Bridge was a good example we would like
try and cut that early in the year
because it always comes up as a
complaint very quickly so why not get in
before it becomes a complaint so there
will be ones that I could probably pick
out I wouldn't say there's a a formal
way of doing so we just have to look on
the expertise of the Rangers but
certainly we can produce something like
that thank you um that was one of the
questions that determined my thoughts on
another
recommendation um because if we can
provide a scale or a report on the
priorities areas then perhaps we may
look to part fund this going
forward so if that report was to
accompany recommendation
one to the
exact they may then wish to prioritize
those areas of safety
over and above the whole of the Rangers
work
y if I may um so I think my only caution
on that would be that um really is
they're a team of two um I think it's
all on nothing at that point so you you
really want a team of two or or not at
all so if you part fun night i' you know
I I'd struggle really thank you no You'
have answered my question thank you very
much um Marcus uh councelor woodon you'd
like to come back thank you madam
chairman um certainly in terms of the
recommendations because we seem to be
approaching that point I would like to
see the recommendation split into two um
and actually to have um the first
recommendation to continue the highways
Ranger Service as one
recommendation uh and then um I have to
say how it is funded is still a matter
of issue for me um but but I've got no
problem with the wording as it is there
um but uh I just think the two
recommendations should be separated
because I don't think there's any
difference between any of us here you're
making a recommendation that we support
the the service um it's how it is
achieved how it's funded part funding
Parish funding Town Council or a
discussion with E6 County Council so I
don't think we're in the position to go
firm on the
solution okay thank you councelor won in
which case I need to ask you to
um word your recommendations and then
seek a seconder for those I thought that
was going to be coming Madam chairman um
I would suggest that we amend
recommendation one as it's currently
written and split it into two uh by the
first recommendation reading um that uh
we agreed to continue the highway Ranger
service full stop and uh then uh
recommendation two being um the rec the
highway Ranger service be funded via the
financial savings as outlined in
paragraph 2.3 of the reports or other
alternative
means thank you do you have a
second counc Foster thank
you Marcus have you got any comment on
those
recommendations no it seems quite
reasonable thank
you um I would like a show of hands
please for the amendments to
recommendation one and the addition to
recommendation two please if you could
all raise your hands if you're in
favor that's unanimous thank you
members sorry chairman a point of order
I think I think um councilor Booth voted
but he joined the meeting halfway
through the debate so that probably
voids his
vot um it's absolutely fine for
councelor booth to vote it's not a
regulatory committee thank you thank
you
so um that um is the last item uh the
recommendation one has been amended and
recommendation two added uh members have
voted on it it was unanimous um so that
members takes us nicely on to our next
item which is the key decisions document
so members are there any questions on
the key decisions
document Council sparing chairman thank
you um can we I'm not sure if it's
appropriate to ask this question now but
in in the key decisions document it
refers to the skate parks in hullbridge
clemet Hall and rayy Leisure centers and
yet had at for Council the other evening
we were told that only two of these are
now on the consideration
Stakes can we ask in at this forum why
um or or or is this not appropriate
thank you
chairman um I think our officer will be
able to answer that hopefully thank
you I think just a further review of the
location of of the sites so just get
some consensus of the two of them were
um as agreed previously I think the the
last one is just some further details
that come up about concern being close
to resident so just being
reviewed so so two two coming forward
and one we're um just looking to review
this stting then bring it back
in thank you and my understanding is
that key decision document will be
reviewed and come back so okay thank you
um any other members wishing to speak on
the key decisions
document
thank you then members um if we can turn
to the work plan um agenda item number
eight members are there any questions um
or noting on or any discussion on the
work plan as it is in front of
you uh councilor
W thank you um on tonight's meeting as
listed we got Highway ranges but
additional details to consider the
council's treasury management report
prior to its submission to
council can you explain the omission of
this
um uh I'll apologize on behalf of the
officers Council award that's a typing
error that should have been removed it
was originally on there but of course it
was coming back to us too soon so that
should not be in the additional details
at
all
December in December yeah um that comes
forward to us next month in
December members any other questions or
any items that you would like to put
forward for the work
plan Council W sorry Council cross
um I can't see it on there but um I I
think we mentioned uh to have a
representation from Essex County council
with a view to discussing the deplorable
state of the uh Lighting in the district
and um the roll out of the LED
replacement program which seems to be a
standard excuse for lights not being
repaired so I think they've got a few
questions to answer
really
um our officers are advising the council
AC cross that they will not attend one
of our meetings if we invite
them sorry unless we invite no if we
invite them they will not attend one of
our meetings oh
okay councilor Foster U thank you
chairman under the 9th of January
2024 meeting um
just talking about improvements within
the development management team I I
understand there been a significant
number of
Departures quite imminent so I think um
we should include a statement about um
reviewing the uh replacement process to
make sure that uh the team is fully
staffed um you want that included within
the report for the review of
improvements within the development
management team yes hold on a moment
please councelor
Foster councelor Foster I've been
advised that's a operational issue for
the head of paid staff so that won't be
taken forward to January okay thank you
chairman any other members
indicating um one thing I will say is um
due to um various reasons there had been
a shuffle around of some of the items on
our work plan hence there was still that
uh tyo in included in there um working
with officers what we have set down
there will be what's coming forward at
each meeting okay because we don't want
things pushed back any further otherwise
we won't be able to um cover them
so any other members wish to raise
anything or have anything added to the
work
plan
no thank you then members um that
actually concludes our
meeting